my friends this story from the daily
mail is a really good example of our
political dysfunction
aoc bursts into tears as iron dome's one
billion dollar funding is overwhelmingly
approved in-house
420 votes to nine
rashida taleb is accused of
anti-semitism by fellow democrat after
she called israel a violent apartheid
system
nine
nine
that's what aoc represents she got 12
million followers on twitter
this is what you need to understand i'm
going to start off and i'm going to give
you the hard facts and then we'll talk
about this stuff
aoc
does not represent her district
aoc represents fringe political
individuals across the country who
funnel money into her district which she
uses as a vehicle to sit in congress i'm
not saying that as to disparage her
character but to point out
her ideas probably don't fly in her own
district the things her district cares
about they probably don't know what
she's talking about but as nancy pelosi
said you could take a glass of water
with a d on it and it's going to win in
nancy or aoc's district that's what
nancy pulls in my or her district so
what happens is there's no real
republican competition there's no strong
primary aoc has too much money from
external sources the same is true for
other squad members their politics are
popular with fringe political groups but
a fringe political group is still
substantive when they can coalesce
online and funnel funding to politicians
like aoc
this manifests in aoc wanting to defund
israel's defensive system the iron dome
isn't bombing children it's protecting
israel from rocket attacks now by all
means criticize israel for all that
stuff i'm just saying iron dome that's
the job it does if you want to defund
israel's home like that why take away
the iron dome of all things that's what
aoc tried to do and as you can see
overwhelmingly like i mean beyond
overwhelmingly you get to see that auc
is shown
what her politics really represent
nobody now i will say
there are a lot of conservatives
libertarians were pointing out yet but
we shouldn't be funding the iron dome
why is the u.s giving a billion dollars
to israel for this and my attitude is
not you know i'm actually partially in
agreement with that i actually think
it's a great argument why are we funding
all this stuff even south korea even in
germany
that being said and we can discuss this
it represents that aoc is not in
alignment with where most people in this
country are when they think about
providing support to our allies now
people can certainly say afghanistan is
bad but israel's a different story it's
an allied united states in a war-torn
middle east that provides stability and
people support that whether you agree
with americans foreign policy or not
i think we we can see here perhaps uh
just good evidence aside from like all
the stories where you see the media
lying there's another good example of
how broken our political system is
i don't know if you guys have any
thoughts
i saw uh i think it was around occupy
wall street that something came out and
said the congress is like doesn't do
what the american people want they do
what their business associates want so i
think that this
massive 460 to 9 vote or whatever isn't
necessarily indicative that the american
people want it but that the politicians
and their business contracts want it
i
i somewhat agree with you uh it is it is
true that uh congress typical like
public opinion typically does not move
congressional votes
but i gotta say man i do think the
majority of americans want to make sure
israel's not blown off the face of the
earth that's a big that's definitely a
big sticking point especially just even
when you look at moderate democrats i
mean they still have a healthy respect
for israel and you know there is still a
very big religious sect
section of our country and you know
israel holds this specific significance
you know whether or not you want to
debate against that or you want to
debate for that
a lot of people israel's still near and
dear to them now i have the question
though for aoc
why do you want to see brown people get
blown up
like why
and it's it's just it's just a it's it's
a mindless talking point it is like
there's a legitimate talking point in
why are we providing funding you know to
these foreign like we should america
first is an argument right yeah we
should fix the pipes in our own cities
and the streets and the infrastructure
before we but then there's the art like
there is there's a legitimate argument
for the middle east is horribly
destabilized israel is a stable nation
they're an ally yes i get the argument
on the libertarian stuff about fun you
know funding and foreign policy stuff
okay i get that but we're not talking
about sending in troops we're not
talking about uh um
you know occupation we're talk we're not
talking about allowing them giving
selling weapons to the saudis we're
talking about the iron dome now if you
want to talk about israel being bad in
terms of how they what's going on with
gaza and the missile strikes
i'm fairly moderate on this one i do
think the real
the yeah i think the real argument comes
from the libertarian position not
necessarily just uh right wing just the
general
why are we focused on foreign excursions
the founding father said we shouldn't be
doing this kind of stuff and we are okay
fair point
most americans i think recognize that we
have international allies and that
israel is particularly vulnerable with
all of these different places in the
middle east i want to blow it up so we
provide them with military support and
out of 3.5 trillion a billion isn't as
much i got to say if you come to me and
you tell me that they want to do 12
million for pakistani gender studies
i'll be like that's insane if they say
we think there should be a missile
defense system for israel i'm like well
that i understand
now i'm a bit of a mild toast fence that
are on this one there's a foreign policy
argument versus a supporting or allies
argument the point is
aoc doesn't represent
like
does it doesn't represent america on
this in this regard i think she doesn't
represent america on most anything she
represents the french minority she
doesn't even go there i mean it's a odd
position to have number one
that you know it's a defensive system as
you've reiterated time and time again
why do you not want a nation to be able
to at least defend itself you okay you
can take the side that you want that you
side with hamas you think that a lot of
people
over there on that side have been
basically disenfranchised by the israeli
government and again
that's the conversation to be had but at
the same time
why do you want to basically disarm a
group and allow them to
be vulnerable to more combat more
injuries and proliferate the same
warfare that you complain about israel
you know just engaging in that's that's
a big issue so i'll say this too ian
like i definitely agree with you on the
politicians are just supported by their
big corporate donors and and and the
political action committees what do you
think would happen if we defunded the
iron dome
oh there you'd probably see more attacks
on israel i would imagine that's a vague
way of saying what might happen and what
will those more attacks result in
with no defensive capabilities
you know obviously like death and
destruction of the infrastructure i
think it's a really kind of a structure
you have the infrastructure i mean the
people will start getting kills death
death and destruction of the
infrastructure it's it's kind of
it's kind of like a pie in the sky kind
of an ignorant thing to be like if we
stop funding it then it'll go away i
mean you see what cutting things out
cold turkey did over there in
afghanistan right again you can say what
you want yeah we shouldn't have been
over there but now that we're in it
again you cannot just leave it worse
than you you know worse than you came in
and that's the problem that's all that
goes on purpose yeah again yeah i know
you've said it multiple times they're
punishing the anti-war people they're
like hey this is what happens when
america doesn't get involved people kill
themselves stuff happens a lot of really
great questions have arisen recently
which is really things are getting kind
of weird right so first people were
saying oh we should be in afghanistan
what about south korea
or why are we there and i'm like that's
actually a good point like i understand
why we're there because north korea
there's still a war and because they'd
love to just trample in and they need
support it's a good question you know we
went there because of basically the cold
war these proxy wars and why are we in
germany now that donald trump asked and
we all agreed why are we in germany like
let's get out so afghanistan sausage
i get the idea of like protecting
afghanistan but all of a sudden people
started saying hey wait a minute if we
shouldn't be there should we be in these
other places and i think a lot of these
places the answer is no we shouldn't i
think the answer for afghanistan no we
shouldn't however i think the answer for
afghanistan was don't abandon bagram air
force base and provide logistics so that
the afghan army can maintain defense of
their cities and not let them fall so
quick and then lie about it after
they're sitting up here begging you
begging you for your air capabilities
just
just a little bit just a smidge and
maybe a drone strike here you know hold
off the bad man
for once joe biden for once when you're
being asked ran off on the plug
midnight he did the drone strike but he
killed kids yeah i'm just like 10 people
accomplished right to strike guys right
tennis
we were asking you to to use your
military military capabilities against
the guys who are who are executing the
afghan soldiers
not the kids in the building in the
urban environment
so look
it's the democratic party man i'm sorry
they're a disaster in this regard you
know what else is crazy though is one of
the other things that's coming out of
this political space with the albert
tribalism is now we've even got i think
in florida they're questioning all
vaccine mandates
where they're basically like someone
said oh well you you're saying no
vaccine mandate for coping but what
about mumps and a guy went okay that's a
good point yeah let's get rid of the
vaccine and then i was like wait wait no
don't do that
so that's too fast we're opening
doors that should not be open and again
it's just the democrats are pushing
there you know they're treading on
sacred spaces that you know we have had
long-standing traditions for and now
they're over here trying to erode those
traditions and it's starting to cause a
lot of people to ask questions like okay
so why are we why are we doing it this
way if you're saying that this doesn't
work and the truth is they don't have an
internal layer of consistency behind a
reasoning it's partisan politics at its
finest and it's something that you get
when you don't have two healthy wings
you don't have a healthy democratic
party let me just say that yeah and the
republican party it's finally reforming
under this new populist base so what
ends up happening is that when one wing
is not healthy it's going to try to
choke the other you know
yeah and then what do you get you get
single party politics people like aoc
that sit up here and start pushing these
friends beliefs because again they need
you know they got to say something well
look at um you look at some of these
news stories like today there's a story
about steve bannon
and all these leftists are like steve
bannon admits to planning the
insurrection and then you actually watch
it and steve bannon's like on january
5th i was talking about trump to help
organize a rally and i'm like oh
and they took that and they turned it
into him saying like them saying he
planned the insurrection and then you
get lawrence tribe being like why isn't
the doj acting he's confessed it's
criminal code blah blah i'm like
they they don't know that the fbi said
there was no insurrection or they're
just idiots now imagine this a group of
people who don't know what's going on
who believe all this fake news and false
framing then going and voting on policy
for aoc she got a cold wake-up call like
hey guess what you're in a cult
people don't want this
look i don't like the ford intervention
in forever wars
israel's different i'm i'm it's that's a
rock and a hard place for me because i
understand the libertarian argument of
like let's not just give funding to
israel what's the point and then also
we're not asking for a military
occupation we're asking for an invasion
we're just saying like
these other countries want to wipe
israel off the face of the earth okay
they can get a missile defense system
i'm not i'm not necessarily a big fan of
that idea but i'm also not in the
position where i'm going to be as strong
as i was in afghanistan or these other
countries and be like pull out all u.s
support for weapons and all that stuff
right
it's like what do you do again you're
already in it you gotta you gotta
actually go win it but can i just say
one thing
we need our top meme makers to get on it
make a meme of aoc crying with 420 in
the background
do it this is for american history we
need this come on guys
dude i i like she's legit crying
no i'm not even playing like look at
this
so she's like
she's crying that's crazy to me man oh
god this israel thing is so wild this
israel thing the country of israel then
there's like the jewish population and
it's like a a jewish state i think so
it's like a theocratic state which is
very unique in the world there's not a
lot of them anyway it's very very and
then you go back to the sykes pico
agreement and the balfour declaration
after world war one or during world war
one where they kind of set up israel
i got to stop you right there theater
theocratic countries like the majority
of countries like a religious government
they're hardline they do exactly they do
exist but they're not i guess not unique
but uncommon it's mostly no no most
states aren't religious states they are
they actually are you america's
particularly unique russia's not uh he's
not african i think you're wrong
if i'm wrong weren't we founded on deism
or like um just the the having the
ability to question but knowing that
there is a power i can't quite remember
we're not a christian state ah what is
what i mean it like it's a jewish state
it's like a jewish state well they are
the only jewish state but there are tons
of middle eastern countries that are
like muslim states like a lot a lot of
them i don't know about asian well like
um lots of asian countries as well
there's some muslim asian countries
there's india is like a buddhist right
yeah i don't know
the indian subcontinent is very
religious but i know far east asia you
know they're a little bit interesting
because yeah they are very like
technocratic they're they're moving
beyond a lot of unified religion and i
mean you just have too many religious
practices there anyways that you can't
have a unified state religion right
right and that's it's not a problem i
mean it what sometimes i think what
confuses is that judaism is a religion
but
judaism is also a bloodline right so
that's unique in all religions there's
no other religion where you're like a
christian by blood it's always do you
choose to become
true but i don't think the belief
structure of the people in israel is the
issue here and i wonder if i wonder if
part of the strong reaction to what aoc
wanted was because of what happened when
we pulled out of afghanistan you know in
a way it kind of is because the jewish
population not maybe not needed but they
didn't have a place to live they were
like persecuted throughout time for
whatever reason and so they needed a
place to find
to live to settle and it was either
going to be in northeast africa and then
they decided to move it to where it is
today i got a i got an update fact check
um 80 countries have a state religion
out of 195 countries in the world so i
would i would argue that's fairly yeah
yeah almost almost almost half
almost half so maybe maybe uncommon is
a little unfair
completely what makes it unique is that
it's a culture and a religion that's
very unique judaism is incredibly unique
um i when you look at the way it was
formed basically the british and the
french betrayed the arabs to form it so
the arabs have had this stick about i
want that land you told us we could have
that
you're treading on on thin ice yeah look
at the sykes pico agreement so the arabs
betrayed the ottomans in world war one
and that's how basically the allies won
the war the the french and the germans
or the the british and the french won
the war and the the french and the
british promised the arabs that area
nations right uh maybe yeah i'm not 100
sure and and then so when they they won
the war the arabs betrayed the ottomans
and our side won and then they they you
know they said sorry we're not going to
give you that land now and so the arabs
are like it's 100 years later and
they're still like it's you you said it
was ours
here's here's what i say to most people
right there's there's there's really
interesting challenges when you have
older generations making political
arguments off experiences the younger
generations don't have i grew up in a
world where there's the
israeli-palestinian conflict it's a it's
literally there's war going on and
everybody wants to make justifications
for why some one country should should
have control of this land or that
country or this land or this state
agreement two-state agreement one state
agreement and i'm like
yo i wasn't alive for most of this and
over time there's attrition in
the conflict was started by people who
are long since dead
and we're now at a point where
you can make any argument in the world
you want for land ownership but
throughout history its people and land
are conquered and i'm not a fan of war
and i'm not a fan of of uh provocation
and aggression but at this point
i don't know
and so so right now it's just like yo
stop fighting
hey get a missile defense system so you
can stop the missiles it's kind of like
the monkey it's kind of like the monkey
in the ladder thing you know something
becomes tradition originally the
tradition had a pragmatic purpose but
then at some point
people just constantly repeat that
tradition over and over and over again
until the original meaning was lost even
if it didn't exist but now the question
i have is
if you support israel
but you're also fairly you know
conservative does that mean that you
support a post-national authority
making such a big ruling such as this
land should be ceded to the israeli
because that's what the league of
nations is and we fought against
post-national authorities like again
like um the eu you know that whole deal
trying to have this whole one world
order type of thing that's what they
tried this that was back in the day and
they're still they're doing they're
still i mean they still want to so do
you support that because that's that's
basically the argument that i hear a lot
of times when they say that you support
israel's right to be a country you say
that post national authority that's long
gone long dissolved
supersedes anybody else's claim to that
land
you know we got this this is this is a
much too complicated subject for like
you know i would say i don't support
post-national authority but israel is a
country now it's there so we can't
pretend like we're not deciding whether
or not we're going to create it anymore
it's there it's like afghanistan we
shouldn't have just pretended like it
never happened and disappear we can't do
that with israel israel is a real place
we got to treat it well there and their
challenges with the west bank yeah
palestine supposedly is a real place you
know but i don't i don't i don't i don't
have enough knowledge yeah we you know
i'll get flack if i'm like hey the west
bank and the illegal settlements what
the what's up with that and then i'll
get two completely distinct arguments
two completely distinctions of facts and
i'm like this history is so deep seated
that you can't you you can actually look
up historical sources that will
contradict another historical source and
it becomes impossible exactly two too
many motivations uh we just have to let
it play out in hope
and you know depending on your religious
prediction pray that there's some kind
of peace there i would pray for
religious tolerance among the the arab
what is it the did you
the judaist population the jude the
jewish population and then who the arabs
are muslim muslim population like
the united states is so wonderful with
our religious you know congruency that i
would love to see that there i
in israel
it's like i've been in tel aviv you walk
around everything's like it feels like
america almost i mean obviously people
are speaking hebrew and i couldn't speak
like a hebrew so i was unable to like
shop
but i'm walking around and it was just
like people going to malls and you know
there was like food carts and stuff it
was just fairly urban and sec like i i
say secular in the sense that
people wore regular clothes like you'd
experience in any any major city i've
been to egypt
and
when they're when i was at the hilton at
a casino and egyptian citizens are it's
illegal for them to enter they've been
to morocco saying like they have these
laws it's very very very different
so
you go to israel and a lot of people are
like it's a very secular place in the
middle of a lot of religious theocracy i
feel like that's almost the
prototype and i know there was a lot of
financial interests when it came to
afghanistan but i feel like that was
kind of the prototype for what we were
trying to set up in afghanistan you know
minus again halliburton and all the
military contractors and again setting
up that whole counter turkey pipeline
deal you know having staging area over
that way thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you